on that topic
um do you have advice
like what advice would you give to a
young person
about life a young person about life or
a young person about
life and robotics uh it could be in
robotics
it could be in life in general it could
be career
it could be uh relationship advice it
could be
running advice just like they're
that's one of the things i see you like
to talk to like 20 year olds
they're they're like how do i how do i
do this thing
what do i do um if they come up to you
what would you tell them i think
it's an interesting time to be a kid
these days
everything points to this being sort of
a winner take all economy and the like i
think
the people that will really excel
in my opinion are going to be the ones
that can think deeply
about problems um
you have to be able to ask questions
agility and use the internet for
everything it's good for and stuff like
this and i think a lot of people will
develop those skills
i think the the leaders
thought leaders you know robotics
leaders whatever
are going to be the ones that can do
more and they can think very deeply and
critically
that's a harder thing to learn i think
one one path to learning that is through
mathematics
through engineering
i would encourage people to start math
early i mean i
didn't really start i mean i i was
always in the
the better math classes that i could
take but i wasn't pursuing
super advanced mathematics or anything
like that until i got to mit i think mit
lit me up and uh really started
the life that i'm living now but
yeah i really want kids to to dig deep
really understand things building things
too i mean pull things apart put them
back together
like that's just such a good way to
really
understand things and expect it to be
a long journey right it's uh
you don't have to know everything you're
never going gonna know everything
so think deeply and stick with it
enjoy the ride but just make sure you're
not um
yeah just just make sure you're you're
you're stopping to think about why
things work it's true it's uh it's easy
to lose yourself in the
in the in the distractions of the world
we're overwhelmed with content right now
but
you have to stop and pick some of it and
and really understand
yeah on the book point i've read um
animal farm by george orwell a
ridiculous number of times so for me
like that book i don't know if it's a
good book in general but for me it
connects deeply somehow
it somehow connects so i was born
in the soviet union so it connects to me
to the entirety of the history of the
soviet union
and to world war ii into the
love and hatred and suffering that went
on there
and the uh the
corrupting nature of power and greed and
just somehow i just that that that book
has taught me more about life than like
anything else
even though it's just like a silly like
childlike book about
adam pigs it's like i don't know why it
just connects and
inspires uh the same there's a few
um yeah there's a few technical books
too and algorithms that just
yeah you return too often right i'm i'm
i'm with you uh
yeah there's uh i don't and i've been
losing that because of the internet
i've been like uh going and i've been
going on archive and
blog posts and github and and the new
thing and
of um you lose your ability to really
master an idea
right wow exactly right
you